hey you two it's time for me to complain
about you two again aye aye I know can
someone just stop YouTube from their
self I feel like YouTube is like a
toddler playing with knives and you
let's just stick the knife away from
that baby stop stop doing stop now if
you don't know what I'm talking about
you probably don't know what I'm talking
about because it doesn't affect you in
any way possible so later you can click
away the video right now I mean no it
matters damn it I don't know if you
notice this this has been a problem for
a very long time
number one YouTube I'm subbing you from
a channel even though you didn't unsub
number two videos not appearing for the
person you subscribe to remember
remember the sub feed remember when that
was the thing this is what we get now we
get their recommended
where's the [ __ ] sub feed oh it's
there no one clicks on it now I used to
be subscribed a tree through a tree and
I was like why am I not seeing their
videos well I'm unsubscribe for some
reason why a channel that I've actually
watched like regularly why would I be
unsubscribe and then channels I haven't
touched in [ __ ] years I'm still
subscribed to how does that make any
[ __ ] sense now you may have noticed
that my channel is dying
okay now let's let's just get that out
of the way okay my channel is it's going
down it's going down hard if you're if
you're still here you need to get the
[ __ ] out cuz it's not gonna be pretty
for my one I'm using reverse psychology
please stay
I clearly [ __ ] need you well
basically when when I was doing the
daily vlogs I noticed how really poorly
they performed I was really surprised by
this because generally vlogs do really
well and last year I did them and they
were fine but I noticed like some videos
didn't even get 2 million views I know
they didn't even get 2 million but
that's really bad for me that's unheard
of for me for the last 4 years probably
3 4 years so for that to happen I I must
be really doing badly to my standards
they're pretty high so I'm like well I
guess people don't like the vlogs
but it was weird because all the
comments
really supportive and and really
appreciated but I could tell that people
just weren't clicking on them so I you
know we started doing this clickbait
joke just to kind of draw people in
I felt I filmed all day but I got no I
got no interesting title I got hit by my
own car hit by my own car you got to get
a good frame in and that's how you make
a youtube video and honestly like a
reason why I I made this video where I
said I'm quitting the blogs part of it
was because I thought no one liked them
I thought that people didn't enjoy them
and that's why and it's already adding
all this stress so I was like well it's
not worth that if you know people don't
like the content I'm making we're
putting all this effort into it and
we're too stressed out and too busy and
it was really a rough time for me now I
figure it out it's because YouTube
changed they change how you view videos
I asked you to respectful I wrote a
really nice polite email
[Music]
and YouTube said well we don't know
what's happening
mmm can someone stop you to prove
themself please all I want is that the
people that subscribe to me get to watch
my videos I don't give a [ __ ] about
whatever else you do okay
but that seems like the core foundation
of pretty much this most simple [ __ ]
thing that you need to do oh and don't
unsub me from channels that I'm watching
now what you can do you can double
subscribe now hey what a great idea
let's make the subscription [ __ ]
useful listen now they got a double
subscribe so hey 49 million people that
I collected overs over 6 years of hard
work hey could you do me another favor
that'd be great just click on that
little little bell there and then just
be like saved not on a streets channel
on my channel bail me bro welcome I hope
you enjoyed the video drop a bell if you
like is that what I'm gonna have to do
now so what they're doing instead is
that they're recommending videos about
people that you don't give a [ __ ] about
you get recommended whatever the [ __ ] is
on the trending time sorry so a lot but
I don't care what's in your back ok your
subscribers do I am sure but keep that
[ __ ] away from me
ok as far away as possible thank you I
feel like I want to work at YouTube and
just tell them how to do [ __ ] I want to
just be like hey hey everyone stop just
stop just you can go home hey I got a
crazy idea how about we how about we
just put back the subscriber feed how
about that the thing that we had since
the beginning of [ __ ] thing that
seems to be working just fine what I
think really is why YouTube is so great
is the relationship or like you watch
someone on a more personal level I don't
think you guys come back just to watch
some Swedish [ __ ] for a few minute I
care about me and you care about what
I'm doing like that's what I like to
think let us have
at least but it seems that YouTube wants
to promote all these random ass [ __ ]
videos that you don't give a [ __ ] about
that's what they want to promote instead
instead of you getting the videos of
these person that you choose to
subscribe to and you that you really
enjoy the entertainment that you really
enjoy consuming and really what this
does this changed us is that it makes
the problem of YouTube having too much
clickbait you get even more clickbait
because top 5 videos or top 10 videos
these [ __ ] [ __ ] ass videos like
videos that are have nothing to do with
personality has nothing to do with
content just has a really great title
and a really great thumbnail 10 million
views is six days ago
it is really upsetting how they did this
change they won't explain what happened
properly to anyone it's not just me but
a lot of youtubers are noticing this and
the fact that I added just a huge amount
of stress when I was already like
filming a show for YouTube it's really
[ __ ] sad and really discouraging I
find that a lot of people that work with
you to almost anyone have no idea what
it's like to work on YouTube as a
content creator as someone who's built
this for years and really cared about it
it's it feels like a kick in the face
when they make changes and don't tell
anyone about it because this site means
so much to youtubers like me and
everyone else it's not just me it means
the world to us it's something that
we've worked really really hard on and I
I don't think they understand I don't
think they will ever get it if you say
why why this is such a big problem they
never made a youtube video they I don't
know I imagine like a lot of people that
I work with on YouTube they think we're
just [ __ ] record for 15 minutes and
that's it you know it's a lot of work I
know it's like a meme that YouTube is in
a job or whatever and in a lot of ways
no it [ __ ] is and I used to work at a
night club working night shifts and
[ __ ]
that was pretty fun actually but
regardless like I know what it's like to
have a shitty job and YouTube by far by
far it's the hardest job I've ever had
and I ever ever had and probably will
guarantee Lee ever have because every
successful youtuber put their heart and
soul into this and we know our channels
we know if something is wrong and if
something that's changed I I checked my
videos every single day when I wake up
and if something is different and off I
would know about it the only reason I
didn't know about it was because I was
so busy when I was in LA that I couldn't
even have time to do anything
I couldn't check these sort of things so
I thought it was my fault and like I
said this is not just affecting me it's
affecting other youtubers and creators
that you care about YouTube is trying to
kill my channel it is happening it's
clear if you watch my analytics it's
it's all it's all going down there and I
think my videos are better I think
they're really funny and it seems like
you guys enjoy them as well so it's a
shame that it's going in this direction
I'm not gonna let YouTube win I see how
it is it's because I have so many
subscribers they're trying to kill my
channel this is all a conspiracy YouTube
wants to kill my channel it's because
I'm always complaining to them I don't
have family-friendly content I click way
too much huh it's a D
it all makes sense YouTube wants my
channel gone they want someone else on
time someone really extremely cancerous
like Lilly sinks I'm white can I make
that comment but I do think that's a
problem and I'm not gonna let you to win
I'm not gonna let YouTube defeat me so
I've decided the only way to stop my
channel from day
I know you're gonna think I'm joking
right now but I'm going to delete my
channel
I swear to you at 50 million subs
when we hit 50 million a huge landmark
coming up huge deal never never been
done before no one's even close
I am deleting my channel and meanwhile
remember to bring that button
ping it ping that book Joe bring it I
hope this video had a decent enough
purpose I'm sorry was a little rambling
I was supposed to shoot something else
today I will delete my channel once
PewDiePie hits 50 million I think it's
going to be pretty fun I'm excited to
delete my channel and start fresh with a
new shitty channel probably I won't quit
YouTube I'll just delete the channel let
me be like if you enjoyed bail me hard
and I'll [ __ ] your late